>> Tucker: THE GREEN NEW
DEAL IS NOT THE ONLY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW
BURNING IN ITS EFFORT TO
TAKE OVER THE UNITED STATES
ECONOMY AND YOUR PERSONAL
LIFE.
DEMOCRATS ALSO A BILL TO
TAKE OVER HEALTHCARE.
IT'S CALLED THE MEDICARE FOR
ALL BILL HAS OVER 100
CO-SPONSORS IN THE HOUSE.
THAT'S A LOT IF YOU WANT
PERSPECTIVE.
THE BILL AMONG OTHER THINGS
WOULD BAN PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
SO TO PARAPHRASE PRESIDENT
OBAMA IF YOU LIKE YOUR PLAN
YOU DEFINITELY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO KEEP YOUR PLAN THE
PROJECTED PRICE TAG FOR THIS
NO ONE REALLY KNOWS.
HERE IS ONE ESTIMATE.
$32 TRILLION OVER THE NEXT
DECADE.
BUT, COST IS NO OBJECT AS
THEY OFTEN TELL US.
CHRIS HAHN IS A RADIO HOST
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU BY THE WAY FOR
COMING ON.
I KNOW YOU SUPPORT SINGLE
PAIR.
>> ANY TIME.
>> LOTS OF POLLS SHOW
AMERICANS WANT GUARANTEED
HEALTHCARE.
SO IT'S NOT A QUESTION
WHETHER THAT'S POPULAR IT
IS.
QUESTION HOW TO GET TO IT.
I WONDER OHIO CAN YOU SELL A
BILL THAT MAKES IT ILLEGAL
FOR MOST PEOPLE TO PAY
DOCTORS OUT OF THEIR OWN
POCKET IF THEY WANT TO.
THAT'S A LITTLE FASCIST IS
IT NOT?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANY BILLS SERIOUS OF PASSING
THAT WOULD NOT ALLOW PEOPLE
WITH THEIR OWN MONEY TO DO
ANYTHING THEY WANT WITH
THEIR OWN DOCTOR.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
LET'S DISCUSS THE BILL
THAT'S RIGHT THERE IN THE
HOUSE GOING TO HAVE 160
CO-SPONSORS NOT SOME FRINGE
THING BY CYNTHIA MCKINNEY OR
WHATEVER.
THIS IS LIKE A REAL THING
OVER 100 DEMOCRATS AND IT
AUTO WOULD NOT ALLOW PRIVATE
CONTRACTS BETWEEN CITIZENS
AND FITTINGS.
LIKE, WHAT?
>> YEAH, I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
THE FINAL BILL THAT WOULD
EVER PASS.
I DO SUPPORT MEDICARE FOR
ALL AND I THINK THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ALL AMERICANS
COVERED.
AND WHATEVER THE DEMOCRATS
PROPOSE, REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO CALL IT SOCIALISM
JUST LIKE THEY DID WITH
OBAMACARE WHICH IS CLEARLY
NOT SOCIALISM.
>> I'M ANTI-SLOGAN.
I DON'T WANT TO THROW
SLOGANS AROUND.
>> GOOD, ME TOO.
>> MEAT OF THE LEGISLATION
PENDING IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TONIGHT,
AGAIN, THAT HAS OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT FROM YOUR PARTY.
SO, THAT LEGISLATION AS
NOTED TWO TIMES PREVIOUSLY
WOULD BAN PRIVATE CONTRACTS
BETWEEN CITIZENS AND
PHYSICIANS.
IT WOULD ALSO PAY FOR
ABORTION NOW YOU ARE GOING
TO TELL ME MOST AMERICANS
SUPPORT ROE V. WADE.
DO MOST AMERICANS SUPPORT
USING FEDERAL DOLLARS TO PAY
FOR ABORTION UP TO BIRTH?
I DON'T THINK THEY DO NOT
EVEN CLOSE.
>> NO.
>> SO WHY INCLUDE THAT?
>> LIKE I HAVE SAID BEFORE
THERE USED TO BE A TIME IN
AMERICA WHERE WE HAD A
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD PROPOSE THINGS
AND PEOPLE WHO HAD DIFFERENT
IDEAS WOULD PROPOSE OTHER
THINGS WE WOULD MEET IN THE
MIDDLE.
NOW PEOPLE PROPOSE THINGS
AND THEN PEOPLE JUST SAY
THAT'S SOCIALISM, THAT'S
ABOUT ABORTION.
THAT IS BAD.
THAT IS EVIL.
JUST -- I'M NOT SAYING YOU
ARE I'M NOT SAYING YOU ARE.
THE CONVERSATION YOU HAD IN
YOUR FIRST SEGMENT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PEOPLE PROPOSE LEGISLATION
IN AMERICA TODAY.
IT BECOMES A GOOD VS. EEL
MATTER INSTEAD OF DISCUSSING
THE MERITS OF THE POLICY AND
GET TO A PLACE WHERE ALL
AMERICANS CAN BE HAPPY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE MOST
STRAW MAN EVER CONSTRUCTED
I'M TRYING TO DO WHICH YOU
LAMENT IS NOT DONE ANYONE
ASSESS THE ACTUAL DETAILS OF
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD FORCE TAXPAYERS TO PAY
FOR ABORTION UP TO BIRTH.
NOBODY -- THERE IS NO LARGE
GROUP OF AMERICANS THAT
WANTS THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BE A FREAKING LUNATIC
IDEALOGUE TO PUT THAT IN A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT.
>> YOU WOULD ALSO HAVE TO
REPEAL THE HYDE AMENDMENT
AND DO OTHER THINGS.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD YOU PUT
THAT IN A BILL?
>> BECAUSE IF YOU ARE
PRO-CHOICE AND WRITING THE
BILL, YOU WOULD ADD THINGS
THAT SUPPORT YOUR POSITION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ANTICHOICE
WOULD THEN TRY TO AMEND THAT
BILL TO GET TO A COMPROMISE
TO BRING 300 MEMBERS INSTEAD
OF 230 MEMBERS SUPPORTING A
BILL.
WHICH IS ALL WE PASS BILLS
ON IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES LAST COUPLE
WEEKS.
IT USED TO BE IN AMERICA
THAT YOU WOULD GET
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
SUPPORT OF A BILL.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE MIND AND
HELP SOLVE A PROBLEM.
NOBODY WANTS TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS IN AMERICA ANYMORE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: MAYBE YOU SHOULD
WRITE BILLS THAT AREN'T
RIDDLED WITH TOTAL FRINGE
POSITIONS THAT ONLY CRAZY
PEOPLE SUPPORT.
REALLY.
>> MAYBE SHOULD SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT OR MAYBE PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE WOULD SAY TAKE
THAT OUT OF THE BILL AND I
WILL SUPPORT IT AND THEN WE
HAVE A GOOD CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE BRING
HEALTHCARE TO ALL AMERICANS.
>> OBVIOUSLY IF YOU LIKE
THIS YOU ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN IT?
>> SPEND LESS MONEY ON
HEALTHCARE IN THIS COUNTRY.
LOOK, WE SPENT 16% OF G.D.P.
ON OUR HEALTHCARE.
THE AVERAGE OTHER COUNTRY
DOES.
WILL.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE TALKING
POINTS.
ANYONE WHO WRITES A PIECE OF
GARBAGE LIKE THIS IS NOT
INTERESTED IN SOLVE AGO